when you think about your career you've
owned businesses you've scaled
businesses through bad times obviously
you've navigated them personally what
are some of the things that people
should be considering right now as we're
looking at a potential recession
well i think it's fun to explore
uh this
kind of event and think about it
offensively and defensively so when you
reached out to me this morning and you
uh you asked if we could talk about this
i think that's kind of how i frame it so
like we can make a defensive category
and start uh discussing that and then we
can
talk about like how do you prosper
regardless of political
party in the white house or whether
we're in a recession etc so you want to
make sure that you're doing things that
kind of make money and grow
uh your net worth regardless of those
events so first and foremost from like a
defensive position
i would say live within your means i
think that's a really important
um thing and an important discipline
that
i've tried to deploy
over 20 25 years of being a business
i i had money before bitcoin
and i've done well with bitcoin etc but
you know i've been doing this for 20
years so i don't know if your your
followers or the viewers know kind of my
backstory but you know i may not look
like much uh but that's all by design
so first live within your means that
starts with kind of getting out of debt
you know using good debt um
is
is a strategy you want to deploy but you
also want to take a look at
all of your debt during these times when
you're going to get
if you have variable interest rates
those interest rates are going to rise
now so you need to make sure that you
structure that debt well so if you can
pay off debt
that's not good debt i would do that i
would also look to restructure
debt that's not favorable or variable
and use debt to income ratios to your
advantage what that means is
you want to make sure you make more
money than you spend
a lot of people don't get this right
right you want to make more money than
you spend and you want the amount of
money that you make to far
outweigh the amount that you spend and
remember this during times of economic
need
banks only lend money to those people
who don't need the money right so those
people who don't need the money get the
best terms they get the money from the
banks and those
times that you need a loan from a bank
you will not get it or you will get the
worst terms uh possible so that's the
first kind of defensive play what do you
think man yeah i think that this is dead
on of just like the timeless
financial principles end up being
applied and almost like they're exposed
or exaggerated in times of downturn and
so the idea of just like living within
your means you should do that in good
times or bad times but it becomes really
really important in the bad times uh and
then you're you're also other point
around just like the more that you are
disciplined and live within your means
the better financial position you're in
which then means that you have
optionality during bad times and so
whether that's loans whether that's uh
you can go on offense you can do all
these different things uh it becomes
really really interesting uh because i
think a lot of people just say hey in
the good times i want to get rich and
then in the bad times like oh i gotta
you know all of a sudden scramble and
figure it out so i i think that's a a
great point what what else do you think
people should be doing from like a
defensive standpoint other than just
living within their means
yeah so this is a transition moment
between offense and defense
i i believe that you should have
multiple streams of income and here
here's where that becomes valuable if
you're someone that has multiple jobs
let's say
i have nine jobs
at this moment nine jobs and multiple
full-time jobs
if i don't like one of the full-time
jobs i can get rid of it and if one of
those full-time jobs don't like me they
can get rid of me but it doesn't affect
me as badly as if i only had one
and then if you structure these multiple
streams of income to be
you know stocks or investments that pay
dividends
real estate
um that's rental properties
uh other passive sorts of uh of income
you can really diversify this is one of
the the spaces that i like to talk about
diversification a diversified
revenue
is a stronger revenue in my opinion so
taking on more jobs taking more more
responsibility having assets that pay
you dividends both passive and actively
uh rental properties etc i love that
strategy going into a recession taking
that list of nine jobs that i have and
always pressure testing them saying am i
doing the right thing the most effective
thing with my most valuable resource
which is my time
when you think about um let's say the
passive income right
how diversified do you think somebody
should be is this something where like
hey if you have two different uh
versions of uh passive income then
you're probably good or do you try to
get as many as possible like what like
how do you just think about passive
income
in these times
you know i don't want to be a mile wide
and an inch deep but i do like to have a
diversified
a diversified
passive income strategy so i do like
real estate real estate does really
really well traditionally
in um
in these kind of inflationary times even
during a recession
i like to have multiple jobs you know
whether it's consultant work or stuff
i'm pulling a lever and actually making
money for i think it's really important
and i think diversifying them
um is interesting for someone like me
who likes to play around in different uh
like investment themes
um it's natural whether i'm making money
in bitcoin mining
power generation trading commodities
real estate
it feels very natural to me and and some
of your viewers uh that have gone
through your evolution pump which you
know your early stage venture guy
big time bitcoin
and now you're talking about business um
and investing across all these thematic
verticals i think your listeners are
probably interested in that as well yeah
one of the things that i think folks
usually forget is uh in order to invest
let's say that you're not in the
investment business you don't manage
other people's money etc a key part to
investing is actually where do you get
the money to invest and you know plenty
of people will say oh like all these
folks uh that i see out there in the
media et cetera they just inherited it
right well usually what ends up
happening is that majority of folks like
80 of millionaires inherited zero
dollars in america and so those 80 of
millionaires they end up actually
figuring out either one building a
business or they may be a lawyer a
doctor you know have some level of high
income uh as well but being able to make
money before you actually have money to
invest is a really important part and it
always feels like especially young
people today with the gamification of
some of the markets and kind of the meme
stocks etc everyone wants to go from i
don't have a job i don't have any money
to i'm an investor but actually
historically it's been go build a
business to get money or go get a
high-paying job to get money and then
once you have money then you become an
investor right
yeah i love this point and and um
it reminds me of one of my favorite
books by robert kiyosaki it's cash flow
quadrants so cash flow quadrants if you
haven't read it it kind of um
it lays into what pom's talking about
in the four quadrants you have
being an employee
an employee has the safest position
has benefits has
small amount of responsibility very
structured and as long as the boss makes
the right decisions and you do what the
boss says you you have a job
then there's an evolution
people go to college and they become
educated and you move into uh this
uh situation where you become
self-employed and it's not always like
four-year masters whatever it could be
technical school or you could be
entrepreneurial but the other quadrant
across from it is self-employment and
it's a very dangerous position so
there's doctors lawyers plumbers etc
most of the time those guys eat what
they kill
and they are
responsible to pay the bills to pay the
employees uh or pay themselves and um
usually you're paying yourself last in
that situation it's a
great kind of um
misnomer i believe or it's kind of the
the position that a lot of us were sold
by our parents you know go to school
uh get a career
and uh get a high paying job it that
high-paying job as doctors and lawyers
was kind of in this
self-employment bucket and a lot of
those people get disenfranchised there
sell their practices take on a lot of
risk
and so you need to be disciplined in
that self-employment bucket and build a
real business
and get into business ownership real
business ownership has
reproducible systems
uh it leverages time so that it's not
just you getting paid per hour per
widget but you have people getting paid
per hour per widget and they're paying
you uh so true business ownership is um
is the kind of evolution and it's a much
safer higher responsibility position and
then finally the last quadrants investor
and there is where you get to either use
your money or other people's money and
monetize your successes
whether it's your reputation or your own
money as an investor you get to monetize
that takes time